[Música]
es que hoy se cumplen cinco años de la
firma de los acuerdos de paz en
colombia' pero recordemos que hubo un
primer acuerdo firmado en cartagena esto
fue el 26 de septiembre del año 2016 que
debía refrendarse en un plebiscito en lo
que los ciudadanos de colombia votarían
el sí o el no el resultado una victoria
para él no lo que obligó entonces al
gobierno del presidente juan manuel
santos a renegociar este acuerdo
considerando las objeciones de los
opositores de este proceso de paz tras
un período de negociación con los
promotores del nou el gobierno y las
farc entonces acordaron un nuevo texto
para el acuerdo de paz el cual se firmó
el 24 de noviembre en el teatro colón de
la ciudad de bogotá a la capital
colombiana este nuevo documento fue
ratificado por el senado y también la
cámara de representantes el 29 y 30 de
noviembre poniendo el entonces fin a un
conflicto armado de más de 50 años la
meta era impulsar la reconciliación
social y también lograr una paz duradera
pero el proceso de paz no ha cumplido
con las expectativas y los constantes
asigna datos libres sociales
exguerrilleros son señales de un clima
de violencia que perdura lamentablemente
en colombia para ello quiero saludar
entonces a nuestro invitado el dia
camilo gonzález posso suele ser
presidente del instituto de estudios
para el desarrollo de la paz indepaz que
dificil emilio encontrar la paz le
pregunto entonces por el balance de
estos 5 años y cómo ha sido el proceso
de la transición a la tan anhelada paz
pero que todavía no se encuentra
muy buen día hoy conmemoramos estos 5
años y creo que tenemos un balance que
es contradictorio pero lo fundamental es
que colombia cambio la verdad es que se
construyó la plataforma para la
transición a la paz y se construyeron
unos pilares nos falta el edificio pero
digamos que en medio de muchos traumas
estamos en ese proceso se ha
desarticulado un conflicto que
representaba el 80 por ciento de las
confrontaciones entre el gobierno y las
guerrillas en colombia y se han iniciado
algunas transformaciones del sistema
judicial de transición también todo lo
que será es la transformación del
partido político y sobre todo un cambio
de mentalidad en la sociedad colombiana
hay una revolución de conciencia a favor
de la paz en contra de la guerra y esto
yo creo que marca muchísimo a pesar de
que la paz no se ha construido de manera
completa que se han encontrado muchas
dificultades para la transición para la
implementación de los acuerdos para
pierre el gobierno realmente este
a la altura de lo que necesita el país
emilio cuáles son las limitaciones y los
retos que le vienen y que le siguen a
este proceso de paz
pues la verdad que lo que se requiere
sobre todo es como reafirmar la voluntad
de implementarlo integralmente ese es el
gran reto porque ha habido una división
en la cúpula del poder un sector muy
radical opositor los que estuvieron por
el no continúa diciendo que el acuerdo
es ilegítimo y quiere desmontar algunos
de los pilares para que particularmente
de justicia y de garantías políticas
para los rectorados pero por eso se
trata de reconstruir ese consenso e
implementar puntos fundamentales que
faltan en temas rurales en el tema de
tierra no se ha hecho casi nada en el
asunto de la acción política y la lucha
contra la corrupción se echó para atrás
la política en materia de drogas de
institución de cultivos y persisten
violencias
muchas recomposiciones de violencias de
otro tipo menores la 'biblia' violencia
ha disminuido en un 95 por ciento en
cuanto a infracciones del derecho
internacional humanitario pero existen
asesinatos de líderes de composición de
grupos armados y esto sobre todo por las
fallas en la implementación integral de
los acuerdos por la falta de decisión
política y por el intento de algunos
sectores de ponerle obstáculos a la
transición a la paz ahí decía también
falta de decisión política emilio y me
quiero quedar con esa frase que usted
dijo para preguntarle entonces como lo
ha manejado el actual gobierno en el
gobierno del presidente iván duque que
recordemos su partido de centro
democrático fue también uno de los
impulsores de él no en este plebiscito y
uno de los grandes detractores de este
proceso de paz en colombia
si el gobierno ha querido reducir la
implementación del acuerdo de paz sólo
en la asistencia y reincorporados de
base que dejaron las armas es decir
quiere transformar lo que fue un acuerdo
de estado la negociación para soluciones
de políticas simplemente en un ejercicio
de sometimiento a la justicia ese ha
sido por eso solamente cumple con
algunos aspectos desde la dejación de
armas de la reincorporación
y mantiene aquello que no puede
desmontar porque se tuvo un gran impulso
durante los dos primeros años y el
gobierno lo puede desmontar pero tiene
una visión muy estrecha pero
afortunadamente este país ha cambiado
hay una movilización democrática
extraordinaria millones de personas han
salido en protestas y dinámicas de
reivindicación entre el año 17 el año
2021 y esa gente está defendiendo la paz
y está entendiendo los cambios
colombianos
y retornar a la violencia a la guerra y
eso ha impedido que el gobierno
se reduzca a la política una política
solamente de desmovilización y de
sometimiento a la justicia pero digamos
que en el área rural también es la
cuestión diferente ahí sí ya vemos
entonces disidencias de las farc e
personas de la antigua guerrilla que no
se adecuaron a este proceso de paz por
el la el inconformismo no y la falta de
implementación real de estos acuerdos
también el aumento de cultivos ilícitos
ilícitos también que estaba comentando y
el asesinato de líderes sociales qué
pasa con esta población rural en
colombia y con estas bandas criminales
al margen de la ley porque digamos que
ya también teníamos concentrada todo
pues la fuerza del gobierno en erradicar
la guerrilla de las farc se radicó esta
guerrilla pero ahora todos se
diversificó en varios grupos esto no
sería en algunos años o en algunos meses
un problema mayor
pues la verdad es que persiste en grupos
pero digamos que es como cuando se cae
un tronco y quedan las astillas las
astillas susan y eso lo que está
sucediendo pero no tienen la misma
capacidad el mismo volumen anterior que
tenemos
si grupos que han proliferado pero no
tienen ninguna posibilidad de poder de
desestabilizar el estado colombiano y
sobre todo encuentran un rechazo muy
grande de la sociedad colombiana que no
quiere la violencia de la juventud que
no quiere otra guerra de modo que si hay
una dificultad golpea y hay regiones de
colombia donde estas conflictividad es
la fragilidad de la presencia del estado
están generando dinámicas de violencia
de muerte asesinatos de desplazamiento
de masacres es algo intolerable que
atenta contra la paz que no tiene los
niveles que tenía antes de la firma del
acuerdo en la primera década de este
siglo pero que en todo caso no nos
permite ni llegar al post conflicto ni
una
completa que se requiere pasar del
acuerdo de paz uno a un acuerdo de paz
de una paz mucho más gente que es parte
de la agenda próxima pero no podemos
decir que colombia ha iniciado una nueva
guerra o que fracasaron los acuerdos de
paz se han implementado parcialmente se
construyó la plataforma y los pilares
del edificio y hay una tarea por delante
que seguramente el próximo gobierno
tiene el reto de implementar de una
manera integral el próximo y los que le
siguen también porque como usted lo dijo
no es una tarea nada a nadie hay más yo
creo que por lo menos en los próximos 15
años estaremos en este esfuerzo de paz y
en estas tensiones con avances y
retrocesos pero yo creo que dentro de
una dinámica fundamental la sociedad
colombiana mayoritariamente le digo no a
la guerra adiós a las armas y estamos en
el trámite de una base de acción difícil